hey I'm Claire Kramer here on the red
carpet for the Furious 7 premiere at the
TCL chinese theatre imax not only is it
the world premiere of furious 7 tonight
but it is the debut of imax laser
technology was popping his head to right
here giving a shout out to the imax
theater that's what's crackin it's
incredible that i get to showcase no to
the wall that's I you know the how much
effort and energy we went to
photographing the movie and all the
sound work so I so it's something
incredible to watch this form on imax
good you know on a regular screen but
it's amazing in imax in a movie of this
size and capacity with stunts that are
just completely unimaginable you know to
see him on a screen that big there's
nothing quite like it it's not being in
the movie it's bigger you can you know
it's literally not being slam-dunked
right in the center of the film don't
get down on a TV you don't get down on a
normal screen you only get it in our
lives there's something so epic about
these movies and and you need to feel
you need to feel it first of all with
another with an audience and make such a
huge difference but the set pieces just
like so
I love the picture and I love the sound
I love the way that the laser is and
it's a shown the way we as filmmakers
wanted it to be you know find the wrong
find been know to you know brilliant
sequences are really proud of doing
dishes classic rock bottom move as he
slams chase them into the glass tape
when the camera speeds with all the
stunts and that exciting things are
happening you want to catch everything
there's just the kind of movie that
needs to be experienced on the massive
massive swing but as I max